hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host John
Carroll we've talked a lot on the
podcast about the idea of thinking and
consciousness right what is it that is
going on inside our heads inside our
brains that makes us a conscious living
being of course a lot of what we know
about consciousness is first-person
right we know about our own
consciousness from thinking about what's
going on inside our heads what do we
know about how other people are doing
they're thinking well of course you need
to be able to communicate you can
observe people and just sort of be
completely scientific about it but most
of our experience with the thoughts of
other people comes from talking to them
reading them talking about them and so
forth so to facilitate this kind of
communication human beings invented
language a symbolic system lets us
represent things and then talk about
them it's then very natural to ask how
much is the way that we think influenced
by our language when we make different
choices about how language should work
those choices can then affect how we
actually do our thinking there's an idea
called the sapir-whorf hypothesis back
in the early days of the 20th century
the strong version of it said that
language actually determines how we
think you can't think in ways other than
the ways that language gives you no one
really believes that anymore but there's
a weaker version that says that language
influences how we think and a growing
number of psychologists actually believe
that today's guest is Lear aboard etske
who is a neuroscientist and psychologist
he's associate professor of cognitive
science at UC San Diego and I got to
know her because in her work on
neuroscience and psychology and language
she talks a lot about time right time is
one of my favorite things so we end up
with the same conferences but the point
is when we talk about time interestingly
we very often use spatial metaphors you
talk about moving the meeting forward
what is that supposed to mean how do you
move us thing in time forward or
backwards just moving something forward
an hour mean it's an hour earlier or an
hour later well that depends on whether
you metaphorically think of yourself as
moving forward in time or the meeting as
move
toward you as you stay stationary
neither one of those ideas is correct or
incorrect
they're just metaphorical choices that
relate a spatial picture to the time
language that we use so Lera has studied
how different cultures use language
particularly do you talk about time but
in other ways as well and you'll fight
figure out that not everyone uses just
simple forward backward language there
are cultures and languages that relate
time - up and down
there's cultures and languages that
related to what compass direction you're
pointing in or where the big mountain on
your island is this kind of stuff
illuminates how we think about the world
in very interesting ways do you have a
long way to go to figure it out Belarus
research is a wonderful window onto the
weird ways in which we without even
knowing it shape the way that we think I
wanted to mention that I do have a
little project that I'm thinking of
maybe trying to start namely doing a
little set of YouTube videos about big
ideas in physics as sort of a way to get
through the coronavirus epidemic
pandemic that we're kind of all facing
it's not really very helpful but it's
something to do something to give me a
sense of contributing some way I know a
lot of people are at home a lot of
people are worried maybe we can have
some videos talk about how the universe
works maybe that will be a fun thing to
do so look for that links to that on my
Twitter feed and web page and so forth
and what I hopefully will be doing is
releasing short videos and then a couple
days later doing also short question and
answer sessions where after the first
video is released you leave some
questions on YouTube or on Twitter and
then I'll try to answer some of the best
ones so we'll see how that goes I hope
everyone is staying safe washing your
hands social distancing all those things
that we need to do you know it's it's a
delicate balance that we have to strike
we have to be careful we have to take
care of ourselves and we have to think
about the welfare of others but we also
have to not panic and we also have to
keep living our lives and it's not at
all obvious how to do that I hope you're
all doing it the best we can so with
that let's go
[Music]
they're aboard to see welcome to mine
skate podcast thanks for having me so I
am physicist I think about space and
time but you know time probably my
favorite dimension in in space time I
wrote a book about time and but from a
physics point of view and one of the
little factoids that I got was that the
word time is the most used noun in the
English language it is yeah this is
sometimes reported as news but it's been
true for hundreds of years but actually
it's also very commonly used in lots of
other indo-european languages so words
like time are in the top ten across lots
and lots of languages we seem to be
obsessed with it is it less true in
other and on your indo-european okay
we're 7,000 languages that's a good
little HD project but you know we we use
the word time in many different ways in
English so it's a bit of a cheat to say
it's the most frequently used word so
because we can say how much time do you
have or how many times have you seen it
or time after time and I'll see you
another time all of those are actually
different uses of the word time or you
could even say time me you know in which
case you're using it as a verb so it's a
it's a bit of a cheat but still we're
talking about time a lot well it
indicates because a lot of people think
the time somehow mysterious and
certainly we're able to use it right
we're able to capture it and you know we
know what we mean when we say be at the
seminar at 1:00 p.m. or something like
that we that operationalize is very
straightforwardly into the world
well we've created conventions that we
require each other to follow but those
conventions aren't actually that
important in a lot of other places so if
you're living in a village in the jungle
making an appointment for Tuesday for
example it's not that useful unless
something happens in your life on a
regular seven-day schedule and actually
Tuesdays are in some important
conventional way different from other
days if not then the seven-day week is a
completely arbitrary imposition on in
the flow of time and in fact lots of
other cultures have different week
structures that they follow well this is
I really want to get into this about how
the interplay of the language that we
use in the reality that we perceive
around it but for
you know you have all these wonderful
examples of the relationship between
spatial metaphors and our use of time so
I just you know why don't we just start
with a classic question of let's move
next week's meeting forward mmm
yeah so if you ask people next
Wednesday's meeting has been moved
forward two days what day is the meeting
now that it's been rescheduled people
often have a very strong intuition about
what the answer is
but about half the people think that
it's Monday and about half the people
think that it's Friday and the reason is
we can talk about time two different
ways in English we can talk about
ourselves is moving in time so we can
say things like we're approaching the
deadline we're coming up on the holidays
so we're moving across a stationary path
which is time right from the past to the
future or we can talk about time is
moving so the deadline is coming up the
holidays are approaching right so we're
stationary and time events in time are
moving towards us these are two
different perspectives and so if you're
thinking of yourself as moving in time
then the meeting moves forward in your
direction of motion from Wednesday to
Friday but if you're thinking about time
moving towards you then forward is in
the direction of motion of time from
Wednesday to Monday and what we find
actually is getting people to think
about themselves moving in space like
scooting in a chair to a goal or
something coming towards them like
bringing a chair to them using a rope
something like that that will change the
way the perspective that they take on
time so if you're thinking about
yourself moving through space you'll say
the meetings on Friday so you prime them
in some sense by making them focus yeah
we get them to imagine one spatial
scenario or another and when they're
imagining themselves moving in space
they get this seemingly unrelated
question about next Wednesday's meeting
and it changes their answer about the
meeting because the way we think about
space and time are so closely related
the 50-50 is fascinating because you'll
have other examples we'll get to about
how people in different languages or
different cultures think about it but
this is the same culture the same set of
people using the same words and still
it's almost equally split or
correlations between you know
personality types do like nervous people
think of it one way and relaxed people
think of it the other way people have
tried looking for personality
correlations and there have been some
small studies I think it's I think I'd
want to see larger samples really to
really be sure but you know what we find
is that even though people might have an
original intuition like if you don't
prime them they have an original
intuition that he's either minder Friday
you can get a whole lot of people to
switch so it's pretty loose it's not
deeply English yeah and it's just that
that use of the word for word is
ambiguous in English just like most
other words or ambiguous it's just in
this case you can get it to be ambiguous
to mean one thing or the opposite of
that thing and presumably it's all
completely unconscious that we're even
using that as a spatial metaphor right
we just use the word and people think
they know what it means
yeah and it's almost impossible in
English to talk about time without using
spatial words so for example if you want
to talk about duration in English
there's no word like duration you have
yeah you say long or you say how much
time did it take right so you talk about
amount you talk about distance other
languages might have dedicated words for
that you use only for duration not for
distance but in English it's almost
impossible to talk about anything with
time without using words that were
originally spatial so you might say I'll
see you at 3 o'clock on Tuesday in an
hour yeah most people sort of think that
the 20th century realization that space
and time are part of the same thing was
like this big counterintuitive thing but
they were always at least very
metaphorically related to us they the
way that we think about lots of abstract
things that we can't see is often
spatial so we kind of use our visual
spatial abilities to allow us to imagine
and organize a lot of other things that
are abstract so whether it's talking
about stocks prices going up and down or
emotions going up and down there are
lots of things that are kind of nebulous
or not directly perceivable by the
senses that we just map into space and
it makes it seem like we can handle it
then in our minds and manipulate it and
think about it more easily
this is probably already hinting at some
relationship between how the brain works
right and how we develop these things oh
I did a wonderful podcast with Lynn
Kelly about memory palaces mhm you know
building these little structures that
have interesting shapes and they let you
remember things so again and analogizing
things in space two things you want to
remember makes it much easier yeah we're
very we do have a lot of capacity for
organizing things in space we have a lot
of experience of navigating spaces in
our actual lives and our actual physical
experience and so then we can draw on
that to reason about lots and lots of
other things are we allowed to say that
maybe the spatial capacities evolved
first before we had a nuanced grasp of
time and other things I don't know that
that would be the case I think a lot of
modern work on neuroscience shows that
there are cells that mark locations in
space-time like that the things that we
used to think where spatial cells are
really more like context and so we were
at a meeting together about this very
idea right yeah neurons in space-time
yeah and so certainly lots of even
extremely primitive organisms need to do
timing right so in order to perform even
the most basic motor action you have to
be able to time things you have to move
one thing and then the other and so
certainly very basic senses of time
exists throughout the evolutionary tree
the way that we end up thinking about
time once we start thinking about the
deep past or thinking thinking about
moving events and things like that
that of course starts leverage you know
it starts leveraging a very different
system but even within the human mind
how we do timing is really distributed
around the brain so if you're doing
millisecond timing for motor movement a
lot of that is going to be in the
cerebellum at the back of your brain
okay but if you're thinking about
something that's on an order of a second
or more than 30 30 milliseconds over
more than 30 yeah more than 30
milliseconds is going to be a little bit
further forward in the brain if it's
something like a minute it's gonna be
the frontal cortex I didn't know that
okay so is that clearly sort of
monotonically related
that it's monotonically related is just
there are really different functions
keeping track of a minute is a really
different task than controlling your
fingers to play the piano even though we
would call them both timing
there's just reports the mechanisms are
totally different for doing those things
and you have this wonderful set of
examples about how the spatial metaphors
and time are different in different
cultures so a range a set of things in
duration right I guess when they happen
you know and and that relates to how you
read and things like that there are lots
of cultural practices that shape how we
correlate space and time so reading
direction certainly makes a difference
so if you read from left to right you're
likely to think that earlier things are
on the left and later things are on the
right and so if I give you a set of
pictures of someone at different ages
for example you're likely to put the
youngest pictures on the left and the
oldest pictures on the right right but
if I give the same task to someone who
reads from right to left like Arabic or
Hebrew then they're likely to put the
earliest pictures on the right and the
latest pictures on the left so the way
that we scan the world or organize
events in our minds is set by this very
simple convention of which direction
your language is written and even just
the way you imagine an event unfolding
so for example if I ask you imagine Bill
is giving flowers to Mary draw me a
picture of that if you ask an English
speaker to do that they're likely to put
bill on the left and Mary on the right
the action is going from left to right
but if you ask an Arabic speaker to do
that they're likely to pull Dylan or I
put bill on the right and Mary on the
left so they're imagining quote unquote
the same event but it's unfolding in
these different directions depending on
their practice reading and writing and
that must be just some arbitrary
accident of history which owes what
right left to right or right to left
it's a little bit less than arbitrary it
had to do with what kinds of writing
implements you had and how much smudging
you would have depending on what you
were using to write with or if you're
using a hammer and chisel for example
you would hold the hammer in your
dominant hand the chisel and your less
dominant hand as opposed to if you're
writing with ink you're gonna use your
dominant hand
because most people are right-handed it
makes more sense to go in one direction
with some implements and in the other
direction with the other implements so
depending on when your writing system
was being developed and some have
switched directions when the implements
changed yeah I remember thinking when
when I first heard about this stuff even
just within physics there are subfields
within physics that draw pictures in
their papers of how time is flowing
almost never from right to left but
frequently from left to right from top
to bottom or from bottom to top there's
no you know cosmologists and people who
do relativity time flows upward but
computer scientists time flows downwards
I really don't know why it's not because
these different implements or anything
like that so it is it is interesting in
different cultures have up and down also
metaphors for time yeah so in mandarin
for example there is a strong up down
metaphor so earlier events are above
later events are below earlier is above
past time flows down well the past is up
I don't know are you moving it's time
moving if you have to set that also
right that's right so if we think of
ourselves as stationary then you would
say the time is moving events in time
are flowing up so that earlier things
and up further and further above you but
the way you would use the metaphors a
Mandarin would be for example to say the
last month you would say the up month
and the next month is the down month and
what we've seen we've seen in a lot of
studies as that Mandarin speakers
actually do use this organization in
their minds privately when they're
organising events in time how do you
test something like that well you can do
it in lots of ways I'll tell you the
simplest one which is I can stand next
to you and I point to a spot in front of
your body and say suppose I told you
this here's today where would you put
yesterday and where would you put
tomorrow
and then you just have to point
somewhere in space and when you do that
English speakers will almost always
organize things from left to right so
they'll put yesterday on the left and
tomorrow on the right
whereas Mandarin speakers will often
organize things vertically putting
yesterday above and tomorrow below
you can also see that in spontaneous
gestures so just get people talking
about time and they'll start using their
hands because we like to use our hands
and so you can see that and you can also
set up little experiments where you
require people to push a button that
means earlier or later and you are very
meanly either placing that button above
or below the Start button and you see
which one is harder for people so if
they have already in their minds an
implicit association that up is earlier
it should take them longer to respond
when you very meanly place the button in
the wrong place and so you can measure
that across lots this is a technique
right in psychology so I don't know a
lot about it of figuring out things that
people don't even know about themselves
by figuring out how long it takes them
to do something is this how reliable is
this how good is this or is it perfectly
established well the technique I'm
describing would broadly be a test of
implicit Association so here you're
asking what implicit associations do
people already have and whatever is
automatic or whatever is very ready for
you to do is going to be easier to do
right you're going to be able to do that
task faster and so often we set up
exactly the kind of thing I described
for you I say well would it be stressful
or difficult for you if I arrange things
in a way that's different from the norm
and so for English speakers for example
it doesn't matter for them if I put the
earlier key above or below they don't
have a strong association that goes
either way
whereas for Mandarin speakers they're
faster if it's above than if it's below
and so that tells us that there is this
implicit association that they have an
expectation that those things are
associated that they have to override
when I do it the wrong way for them
right if there's one thing that human
beings aren't great at its predicting
the future we live in a world right now
where there's a whole bunch of things
going on that we're very hard to predict
at the time but what we can do is
prepare for a different set of
eventualities than we expect one way of
doing this is buying insurance in
particular buying life insurance it can
be a tricky thing to do but that's where
policy genius can help policy genius is
a website which will let you look
through many different possible places
you could buy insurance they're not
giving you the interns
Elves they're helping you find the right
policy you could save $1,500 or more a
year by using policy genius to compare
different life insurance policies once
you apply the policy genius team handles
the paperwork the red tape all of that
stuff so if you haven't found a
play-by-play breakdown of the future
inside a crystal ball that's okay
be prepared for anything by getting the
best price on the right life insurance
policy for you at policy genius.com
policy genius will always get the future
wrong better get life insurance right
okay I just wanna keep getting all these
wonderful examples on the table you also
have examples of just the fact that we
have the words past present future but
some languages slice the blown e much
more finely than that and some less I
suppose yeah well the way that languages
treat time grammatically really differs
so for example in some languages there
is no past tense there is no future
tense there's no there's no tense
marking on verbs at all in fact verbs
never change there are verbs but they're
not tensed yeah but some people argue
whether or not they're verbs but yeah so
the way you would say that you know if
someone if I show a picture of someone
who's about to kick the ball someone in
the process of picking the ball someone
has just kicked the ball there are some
languages where you would just say hey
kickball in all three cases yeah and and
then there are other languages that make
much finer distinctions so in some
languages there might be five different
past tenses depending on how long
something how long ago something
occurred right so if it was within a
week that's one tense if it's within a
month it's another tense and so on and
so you really have to keep track of how
long ago something was and make sure you
use the correct tense and does that
affect how people think about time are
they better at knowing how long ago
things were if they have those words
available you know there hasn't been an
empirical test of exactly that that
language that I was just describing as
this minority language spoken in Papua
New Guinea so it's quite challenging
but but it would be it would be really
interesting to see in general the
prediction would be that whenever you
make a distinction you see things that
fall in the category together as being
more similar and you see things that are
in different categories that fall on
different sides of that the category
boundary as being more different so if
your language makes a distinction
between you know things that happen up
to a week ago and other things then you
really have a separate category in your
mind for things that have happened
within the week and those are seen as
different from things that have happened
within the month but not within the week
and somehow in your brain they keep
changing categories as a week goes by
that's just what's weird to me yeah they
have to continuously fade fade into new
categories yeah I mean I wonder there's
probably not a fair question but do we
know enough about how the brain works to
say that these memories are in our
brains but they get re classified as
they pass the boundary or do we sort of
have to think about oh that that was
three weeks ago so okay it's in this
category well we don't know enough about
the brain to know that I can make an
educated guess which is that when you're
about to tell someone about an event
you're retrieving elements and when
you're retrieving you're adding
information as well this is true in any
in any retrieval case right so if I ask
you about a birthday party that you
attended you'll be able to retrieve some
details that maybe you directly
experienced but you're also going to
fill in a lot of other details from
general knowledge that you have about
birthday parties and what you're like at
birthday parties and all kinds of other
general knowledge that you have and so
in it's in that context of retrieval
that that information gets added or it
gets reclassified so I guess we have
this naive metaphor based on computers
or something like that that images or
files have timestamps right but probably
memories are not quite that simplistic
although clearly we do have some ability
to remember when things happened but I
don't know exactly how it works yeah
well we're remembering context right so
with every with every memory there's
going to be context that you store away
you might know that it must have
happened before this because you hadn't
yet known about that
or you might know that a particular
person was there and you didn't yet know
that person before such and such a time
so you can all you can often use context
to try to yeah I mean that's interesting
it's it's not that it has a timestamp
it's that one memory is sort of
connected all these other memories and
we can reconstruct when it must've been
exactly we but we certainly don't have a
timestamp and mostly we're terrible at
remembering when things happen which you
know may be for the best it's not
usually that important but imagine if
you had an exact timestamp for every
every event that occurred how
fine-grained would you want that like
every time you picked up before I think
in general you kind of know the
relationship between events in your life
more or less do you think in general
that the fact that we're so used to
computers now has given us a bad idea of
how the brain probably works because
they are pretty different so we do have
a tendency to compare brains to whatever
is the most complicated technology
available at the time right so it used
to be that the most common metaphors for
thinking or clay tablets all right and
then after clay tablets maybe it was the
abacus and then it was a calculator and
then it was a telephone switchboard
because those were very complicated then
it was the computer and maybe now it's
the internet and so people draw on
whatever complex things they have around
to try to understand this other
extremely complex thing you see that in
all branches of science right so in
physics the atom used to be a ball and
then it was a bowl of pudding with
raisins in it solar system so you have
you have these metaphors that drive
hypotheses that drive thinking drive
debate and they're always evolving and I
guess we shouldn't just talk about
spatial metaphors for time but even I
want to say spatial metaphors for space
right how people think about space could
be very different how people think about
directions in space for example yeah so
the way that we orient ourselves in
space and which dimensions we think our
primary really differs from culture to
culture
so for example we've been talking a lot
about left and right and the organized
time from left to right for example but
there's some languages that don't really
use words like left and right and
instead they do everything in some kind
of absolute space so cardinal directions
would be an example north south east
west and I had a chance to work in a
culture like this in Australia actually
about a third of the world's languages
relies strongly on cardinal directions
of some sort so as opposed to saying
forward backward left right they say
north-south east-west not exactly not
necessarily north-south east-west this
says a set of directions could it could
be different so it could be if you live
on a hill your directions are uphill
downhill across the hill or it could be
that your directions are set by the
river that you live by or they're just
or they're set by the locations of the
mouth and the source of the river not
the flow of the river or things are
important yeah prevailing winds or they
could just be an arbitrary set of
directions that roughly divide things
into quadrants but are aren't aligned
with north south east and west right so
there are lots of possible systems on
islands there's often a concentric
system where there's a direction that's
seaward in a direction that's like
inland like a volcano word is a and
sometimes you have mixed systems like
you might have a C word inland dimension
but also an east/west dimension and so
people use both east/west that's a very
common because of the Sun of course and
then you also have this more concentric
system that's about how far away you are
from the scene and that does seem like
that linguistic convention would have an
effect on what you understand I mean
right now I have no idea what direction
North is right but if I grew up in that
culture I would probably keep track of
it all the time yeah in fact that's
that's what we find people who speak
languages that require you to use
cardinal directions for example do keep
track of which way they're facing
because you have to speak the language
right so in the community I worked in
literally to say hello you say which way
are you going and the answer should be
something like north northwest and the
farthest survive yeah all right so you
literally can't get past hello
and the social pressure of course to
learn is very very strong you just get
treated like you're a nincompoop if you
don't and even very small kids there are
very well oriented so you know I could
sit down with a four-year-old and say
hey can you draw me north south east and
west and they would just make these two
effortless lines in the sand and I would
get my compass out and be blown away
exactly right you know this tiny little
human you're like how did you do that
what about people whose brains are not
completely functional does that affect
how they perceive these things you know
we had a chance to test this looking at
patients who've had strokes we looked at
patients with strokes in the right
parietal lobe this is a common place to
have a stroke because there's a lot of
vasculature there so it's common for
things to go wrong and when you have a
stroke there one consequence often is
that you start neglecting things that
are on the left side of space on the
other side of space so these patients
might only do right brain controls yeah
yes so these patients might only eat
food on the right side of their plate or
they might only put makeup on the right
side of their face or might only shave
the right side of their face they might
only read words on the right side of the
page they just don't they seem to be
unaware of what's happening on the left
and so we wonder does this also extend
to time so how concretely is time really
on the left or the right I mean sorry
can I just ask like for the plate thing
is there part of their brain that knows
that they're only seeing the right-hand
side and they can just rotate their
plate and there's more food there if you
rotate it for them they'll be happy and
not eat the other side they won't if
they will eat food on the right side of
the plate and complain that they're
still hungry huh so there's something
else going wrong in their brains that
they can't they're just not able to
bring into consciousness those that are
on the left is amazing but yeah it does
undermine the idea that there's a
separate unified consciousness yeah so
obviously your brain is aware of lots of
things that it's not telling you about
it's kind of like on a need-to-know
basis with your conscious conscious
experience yeah
so if you really stress test this like
if you have something on fire on the
left side or you show a salacious image
on the left side people might blush you
know well they might blush but they
might not know why they're blushing and
so anyway talking so yeah so we told
people these these were patients who
read from left to right they're French
speaking patients in Switzerland we told
them about a guy David who liked doing
some things ten years ago in the past
and will like doing different things ten
years from now these are trivial things
like ten years ago he likes cherries but
ten years from now he likes strawberries
and these are just facts that they had
to remember and what we found was when
we tested when we tested their memory
they were much more likely to remember
things that were associated with the
future the right side of time and if
they remembered things from the past
they miss attributed them to the future
so if they remembered something that we
said happened ten years ago if they
recognized that they mistakenly thought
that it had to be in the future so they
kind of squeezed everything in their
mental time line into the part that they
could attend to which is in the right
part of their mental timeline so that to
me shows just how deeply ingrained these
cultural patterns are right so
culturally we've assigned the left side
of time to be the past to the right
right of time to be the future it's a
completely arbitrary convention it's an
arbitrary cultural convention and yet by
the time we're grown adults if you
destroy the part of the brain that
represents the left side of space you
also knock out that culturally
associated part of time so somehow
encoded in the physical brain it is yeah
in ways that we're learning well there's
no other option than for things to be
encoded in the physical brain we don't
have any other hypotheses you think
yeah I mean maybe this is a digression
but I want to hear more about what this
fieldwork is like like how do you find
this tribe with this language how do you
visit them are they presumably a small
tribe it's the particular linguistic
community is about 200 people the the
entire community is about 500 people and
there are speakers of five different
languages that live together in this
community isolated or there yeah they're
pretty isolated they live on the west
coast of Cape York on this town called
Parral it was set up as a mission in
Australia but to answer your question
how do you kind of start on this kind of
work well you always start with a
question or an interesting observation
that catches you and you say well I
wonder and so I ended up doing this work
with a wonderful collaborator Alice
Gabey who was the first to describe the
grammar of the cook Thai language that
was spoken here so so she wrote the
grammar for the length for the language
as her dissertation and she spent a lot
of time in the community and I got
connected with Alice because I had been
bothering one of her advisers for years
about hey you're working with people who
speak these these languages that have
this cool way of thinking about space
how did they think about time - have you
noticed anything have you noticed
anything happen every time it would go
to visit his lab I would constantly bug
him and after years he said oh you know
what Alice noticed something you should
go talk to Alice progress of science
that's how it works yeah but I then
recently was going through some of my
college notebooks and I'm a very
disorganized note-taker and so my
notebook contains some you know notes on
who Cyril and then someone's phone
number a recipe for lamb stew and then I
know a note that said get in touch with
such-and-such a person and find out how
speakers of this language organized time
it would be cool if it's in cardinal
directions and I'd have zero memory of
writing that note and then of course you
know 20 years later you get to do the
study
but it was one of these things where you
just get interested in a question and
you keep asking people who you think
might know and eventually an opportunity
opens up and the gift of a wonderful
collaborator and then you get to get to
find out the answer to the question that
apparently I'd wanted to know for much
longer that I remember did you have to
learn the language no Alice was my
contact on the language front it's how
many languages do you have to know to do
your job it's really useful to know
about languages and it's really useful
to have wonderful collaborators that you
trust who are experts it's always best
to have someone who is more expert than
you and but okay so what's the answer
does it does speaking of space as
cardinal directions affect how you talk
about time it affects how people
organize time in their mind so when we
asked people in this community to for
example organize cards that show person
aging you know from young to old instead
of organizing them from left to right
they organize them from east to west so
if they're sitting facing south they
made them go from left to right but if
they're sitting facing north they made
them go from right to left if they're
sitting facing east they made them go
coming towards their body and for me
that was just the most amazing thing to
see with my own eyes because it's one
thing when you make a prediction
theoretically you say well here's a bold
claim if I think that way people think
about time depends on space and you
build one out of the other then they
should do this thing but it's a thing
you've never seen anyone do millions and
millions of people have been given a
task to organize cards and you've never
seen someone do it that way right and so
you sit someone down and you say let's
see what happens and then you see it
happen before your eyes it's it's it's
the coolest thing to see and in a sense
it's very weird to us to think that I
need to keep track of
north-south-east-west when I put some
cards on the floor but maybe it's a
little bit less egocentric right like
it's not like time revolves around you
it's
or stuck in here inherent in the earth
somehow yeah there's there's definitely
one way of thinking about that pattern
of data I just described that says oh
how weird they make time go in different
directions depending on which way
they're facing but actually the other
way of describing it is oh no they're
doing it in a different coordinate frame
so actually time always goes in the same
direction in the coordinate frame that's
important to them right so they're using
a qualitatively different set of
coordinates and for them it's the court
the relevant coordinates are east to
west and time always goes from east to
west and it's me who is making the
dimension of time chasing me around
every time I turn my body extremely
eccentric of me and is it this is again
you know maybe future research but are
there other correlations so that you
know this is a whole nother category I
hang about both space and time a little
bit differently can we match that up to
other ways they think there are lots of
things that we would want to explore
it's it's too definitely too early to
make other conclusions but people have
found lots of other cool patterns of how
time goes that isn't left-to-right or
right-to-left right so for example my
colleague here at UCSD Rafael Nunez and
Kenzi Cooper writer did work in a
community in Papua New Guinea that
you've know people and what's cool about
the youb knows for them time doesn't go
in a straight line so it rolls into the
village at one angle and then it hits
the village it takes a turn and rolls
out at a different angle okay that's
just crazy so because we've we have
traditionally had all these assumptions
about how time must go right so it used
to be well it has to go from left to
right and maybe it has something to do
with handedness because we're
right-handed so people would have that
kind of explanation or it has to go so
that the future is in front and the past
is behind because we walk forwards
mostly not backwards and we have eyes in
the front of our heads and that in fact
that turns out not to be true either for
some people that past is impressive
all these logical things it has to be in
a straight line of course how else could
it be but it doesn't have to be in a
straight line if there are places around
you that are important to you so in this
case the mouth and the source of the
youb nerve river are really important
locations and there's no way to make a
straight line between them and hit the
village so then
time takes a detour to the village stops
in the village and then takes a turn and
goes in what does that mean
operationally like when you say when
you're referring to something a week ago
it's in one direction and a year goes in
a different direction yeah so if you're
looking at the way people gestures
they're talking about events in the past
in the future you'll see them gesturing
along this bent timeline right more
things that's that's very cool
but I think all of this is a testament
to the incredible ingenuity of the human
mind right that we've invented not one
one way of thinking about time but so
many thousands of ways of thinking about
time and probably we haven't invented
most of the ones that are still possible
these all the ones you mentioned are
one-dimensional right more trouble to
people were thinking of times
two-dimensional cuz I don't not make
sense of it well so the example we
started with when I say next Wednesday's
meeting has been moved forward two days
what day is the meeting you tell me if
you think it's more than one dimensional
so if people are giving me different
answers depending on how they're
thinking whether they're thinking about
themselves moving or time moving now if
time is one dimensional and it's like a
one-dimensional unidirectional entity
then it should not matter if I'm moving
towards the meeting or the meeting is
moving towards me right those are the
same thing in space it matters because
there's a fixed ground against which
we're moving so if I'm moving towards
you that's different than you moving
towards me because there are other
things that are staying stationary
relative to us but that requires more
dimensionality it's not right oh I don't
know I don't think so I think that um I
mean number one of course part of what
Einstein figured out was that the ground
it's perfectly okay to think of the
ground is moving if you're on a train or
something like that right so that you
can choose your reference frame as you
want but even if space were only one
dimensional there could still be ground
and there could still be a reference
frame with respect to which you were at
rest I think the thing that it is having
space be more than one dimensional
enables is that you can go in circles
right
whereas in time you can't go in circle
you only go in one direction well a lot
of cultures do go in circle so they
think they they legalistic we talk about
it that way but well certainly people
draw draw diagrams of time that are
circular or at least imply a spiral and
we have a lot of cycles built into our
systems right so we have the weak cycle
where things repeat in the months of the
year repeat and so on and in some
cultures those circles are a lot more
prominent as a way of thinking than yeah
I know that I mean the standard
paradigmatic clock is a pendulum going
back and forth thread repeating itself
there are definitely cycles in nature
but in general I have described a lot of
things that sound linear and part of
that might be an artifact of the
measurement right so when you're
measuring how people think about time
you give them some cards to lay out they
give you a line well when you're looking
at a line it's possible that what you're
looking at is a small part of a really
big circle pretty much right and you're
just not making a measurement of the
whole system so if it was possible for
us to create a task that measured a lot
more of the space we wouldn't just see a
bunch of little lines we would see a lot
of lines that connect in small lines I
connect into a circle or a rhombus or
something and we're talking about weeks
and months and years but presumably all
these different cultures have their
cosmologies or their eschatology x' or
whatever and so they might have guesses
or hypotheses about what happens on much
much much longer time scales that are
different from culture to culture right
Hindus have a cyclic sort of cosmology
that is like way longer than most
Western cosmologies yeah definitely
people's relationship to deep deep time
whether it's the past or the future is
really different from place to place
I'll give you two examples one is just
how many how many steps of causation do
you think are relevant to a current
outcome so if I set up a pool table and
I say here's the location of all the
balls I'm gonna make a shot how I'm you
know how important is this shot for all
the next shots that I'm going to make it
does it happen does it make an impact
the second one on the third one and the
fourth one and yes students in different
countries this everyone will say the
next shot of course is being affected by
the outcome of this first one but then
people start to fall off and American
students fall off after basically like
the second or third shot so by the time
you make it to the fourth or fifth shot
they say yeah that first shot is no
longer exerting a lot of causal force
and but students in Korea for example
will say even though the sixth and the
seventh shot they still think it's
exerting a lot of causal force and going
the same way in the opposite direction
in the past you say well here's the
location of the balls that's ended up
now how important was the shot before
that the shot before that the shot
before that and again American students
have a much narrower slice of time slice
of causal links that they allow to be
relevant whereas other people have a
deeper have a deeper causal chain that
they allowed to be built it's
interesting because as a physicist I can
justify either one of those approaches
right I mean clearly the shot that you
do right now in principle affects all
the subsequent that's right but maybe in
practice there's enough unpredictability
that it doesn't affect it in a
noticeable way so it depends on which
you care about so you said also about
time being one-dimensional as opposed to
two-dimensional and cycles and I wanted
to tell you about the Balinese calendar
because I'm such a cool example people
describe Balinese time as dense time so
instead of one seven-day week
Balinese calendar has ten concurrently
cycling two weeks there's a one-day week
a two two week a three-day week afford a
leader firing and so all of these are
you have their own rhythms right and
different things happen on different
sized weeks so for example the fish
market might be on the third and fifth
day of a five-day week the vegetable
market might be on the fifth and seventh
day of a eight-day week and so that so
you can imagine the kind of complex
rhythm that this creates in your kind of
understanding of time and also there are
three concurrent years happening so
there's like the Gregorian calendar the
lunar calendar
solar calendar and all of these are also
happening at the same time so if you
have a chance to look at a Balinese
calendar and see all of the markings and
designations and colors and additional
markers that are required to keep track
of all of these it's it's really
phenomenal how do they do this before
they had laptops and things like that I
can't keep track of my appointments next
week I think it's I think that's a
cultural practice that you see also for
example in music and Bali so if you
think about the gamelan and all of the
cyclic complex cycles of rhythm that
happened on the gamla and where if
you're playing one part of the gamelan
you might be a you know on a I don't
know eighty seven count you hit on the
thirty-one in the forty seven and
someone else is on a much different much
different set of times and so I think
that that idea of embedded cycles that
are recurring but of different lengths
and things kind of falling into that
rhythm that's cotton that's ever
existing it's just a very important part
of the culture that permeates lots of
and that does sounds like something that
would I would expect clearly have an
impact on one's cognitive capacities
right I bet the typical Balinese person
who's better juggling all these rhythms
than I ever would be they're trained to
do it right they expect it and so forth
well you said then you ever would be
well I would disagree with that I think
if you if I started young then sure but
now you can learn lots of things it's
this idea that you can't learn things
later in life it's really silly think
about all the things complex things
you've learned since you were six years
old it's true we have this mess I think
we have this somewhat magical idea that
you know children are the sponges for
information and they can acquire these
really complex things and sure that
children are sponges and they learn lots
of things that's very impressive but
adults do pretty well we come up with
some pretty clever stuff imine team
adult yeah no actually a dime I'm very
glad that you called me out on that
because I am a big believer that you can
and should try to learn things
even in your dotage and such as I am but
but okay still I do think that the
practice does affect your capabilities
yeah this other oh absolutely
cultural practice especially something
that's built into your language it's
something you're required to do you have
to do it just in order to be a normal
member of your society you're going to
do it and so it's a daily practice and
if there's anything we know from
cognitive psychologists the things you
practice you get better at yeah let me
pause for a moment to talk about
LinkedIn jobs you know that when it
comes to hiring people decisions that
you make can be the most important
decisions for a company whether it's a
mature one or one that is just starting
up LinkedIn jobs helps match the right
talent to the role that you have
LinkedIn has over 675 million members
worldwide and LinkedIn jobs screens
candidates with all the skills that
you're looking for whether they're hard
skills or soft skills things like
collaboration creativity adaptability
LinkedIn looks beyond the work skills
and puts your job post in front of
qualified candidates who match your
business requirements perfectly it's no
wonder a person is hired every eight
seconds with LinkedIn and why companies
rate LinkedIn jobs the number one hiring
platform for delivering quality hires so
find the right person for your business
today with LinkedIn jobs you can pay
what you want and get the first $50 off
just visit linkedin.com slash mind scape
again that's LinkedIn calm slash
mindscape to get $50 off your first job
post there are of course terms and
conditions that apply okay I mean I do
want to think that we can keep learning
things no matter how old we get maybe
but I sometimes wonder whether I'm just
whistling Dixie like what about learning
languages is it true that we were better
at that when we were younger it's
definitely easier to learn languages
when you're younger than when you're
older it gets progressively harder but
people often use that as an excuse to
not learn another language that I often
have people tell me oh it's too late for
me I'll never you know if I start
learning French now I'll never be
perfect at it I'll never be native like
and I always wonder like why do you want
to be perfect are you trying to be an
international spy
what's what's the cause that's the only
reason why you'd need to be passed for a
native speaker it's actually a really
fun and useful Oh to speak a language
even if it's not perfect you could speak
it pretty well you do sort of discipline
yourself to learn more languages
occasionally I'm trying to learn Spanish
now Spanish okay good I think it's super
fun it's a fun puzzle where you can
actually go in and have an interaction
with someone it feels like you've you've
solved you've like unlocked some kind of
mystery like you said some words and
they said some words back and you got
the taco that you wanted I actually
think this more broadly about academics
I think that you know there's this idea
that we're creative when we're young and
we become less creative when we're older
and maybe there's some of that that is
true but there's an equally good
hypothesis that says when we're young we
don't know anything so we have to work
hard to learn and become an expert in
something and when we're older like
we're already an expert in something so
we can just keep doing that thing over
and over again and that makes us less
creative completely irrespective of our
cognitive capacities yeah so we
definitely get set in habits and we get
set in patterns but once you recognize
that about yourself you can do something
consciously about that right and you can
go and learn new things you can go and
have new experiences this is one of the
reasons that people travel for example
you end up in a different context and
those times that you're traveling that
you're away they expand in memory so you
might have a week of vacation and that
week of vacation takes up so much more
space in your memory of the year than
the rest of the year because you have
new experiences in a different context
they aren't just automatic repetitions
of the your normal routine and so
whether it's learning languages or
having new experiences jostling yourself
to do something new creates that
opportunity for creativity so as a
professional cognitive scientist would
you sign on to the idea that continually
surprising yourself and trying new
things
keeps you young in terms of your brain
function there definitely lots of
studies that show that there's a user
lose it feature it's true with languages
so
people who acquire a second language are
somewhat protected from Alzheimer's and
onset of dementia late in life but
that's also true for any active hobby
that people keep up right so whether
it's digital photography you or
something else that requires you to use
your brain in new creative ways that
will that will help you stay active and
I always tell people that the right the
right time to learn another language is
now it does get harder as you get older
but unless you have a time machine you
could go back to when you were younger
your only option is now and now is
better than any other time that's later
I need to get some like language
learning course to advertise in the
podcast it's a great idea and it's not
just time you have another example which
speaks to this point about colors about
the the light blue and dark blue yeah so
it's a very simple example again when
language makes a distinction between two
things
it requires you to make a distinction
between two things you get a lot of
practice distinguishing them so in
Russian there isn't a single word that
covers the entire spectrum of Blues in
English so there's not a word that
covers everything from the lightest
blues to the darkest blues instead there
is a separate word for light blue blue
boy and another word for dark blue which
is singing and so Russian speakers have
to call different shades of blue by
these two different names and when you
test their ability to distinguish blues
that either fall in one Russian category
or in two different Russian categories
they're faster to tell the difference
between what they would call Google boy
and what they would call see me
whereas for English speakers they're all
just blue so we can tell they're
different but it takes us longer to
recognize the difference than a word of
Russian yeah in general this is true
cross languages you can test English
speakers across the blue green
distinction and things that you would
call blue as opposed to green colors
have fallen either side of that boundary
you will be faster to tell the
difference between them two different
blues or two different greens that you
would call by the same name there's
nothing spooky about that is practice
that's what they're used doing it's
practice yeah
yeah I mean it's so now as we're bumping
up against the big question which is how
we talk versus what is real does the
language bring
reality into existence or is it a simple
representation of reality like I think
you think even men and women even in the
United States label colors slightly
differently right and certainly the
evidence you just said Russians and
English speakers label colors slightly
differently does that mean that we see
differently are we perceiving the world
differently we're gonna go way beyond
colors to much more deep and important
concepts there so of course all we can
measure in experiments is how people
behave right so I can say does it take
you longer to make this distinction or
not are you more likely to confuse these
two colors in memory or are you more
likely to make an error when I'm asking
you to make a distinction what I can't
tell you from any of those results is
what your experience of that color is
right so if your question is do Russian
speakers see those colors is differently
experience them it's somehow differently
I can't tell you what anyone sees that's
a problem it's a problem with
consciousness all these yes perception
is a private experience so ultimately
that's beyond our tools of measurement
so all we can do is say how you know how
efficiently can you make this judgment
how likely are you be correct if we
stress the system things like that and
from that we can we can say well the
brain seems to have an easier time
making this distinction than that we can
also make measurements directly from the
brain and say oh the brain of a Russian
speaker responds if you shift the colors
from light blue to dark blue you'll get
surprise or response so it's like an MRI
machine or something I'm just going to
the brain I'm describing EEG results
whether you're you're measuring a very
fast response that just kind of says
something has changed right so it's like
a surprise marker yeah and if I show you
a series of blues when I've crossed the
boundary from light blue to dark blue
the brain of a Russian speaker a Greek
speaker for example will give that
surprise response it says oh we've we've
shifted category something new is
happening whereas the same series of
colors will not give that response and
in English speakers brain because
nothing the category isn't changing
right
so again we can tell that the brain is
treating these things differently but I
can't tell you that people see things
and anything about how anyone sees
anything really what was it was a good
asset fear war of hypothesis I'm getting
it right anyway
yes if you disappear disappear
sapir-whorf that basically said that our
language controls what we see yeah well
how would you phrase the hypothesis
there are many different versions of the
hypothesis so Benjamin Lee Whorf died
young and a lot of his writings were
published posthumously so they're like
imagine all your notes that you have no
no but in his writings he has lots of
different things a very strong
hypothesis might be that language
controls thought and you can never have
thoughts that are outside of your
language another version might be that
language is one of one of the
contributors to how we come to see the
world and it might be a stronger
influence in some domains where there's
less information from the world there
might be a less strong influence than
others but in general there there is
this interesting idea out there that
says maybe language is a straightjacket
for thought maybe we can't we can't
think outside of the bounds of our
language and I think this is a
particularly odd idea because you know
you can always learn new ways of talking
and also to invent any feature of a
language you have to have at least
partially the thought first and so it
seems to me that language can't be truly
a straightjacket for thought but
language can certainly encourage
patterns and entrench us into ways of
thinking so that we don't even consider
other options I mean I always you know
thought of what about an instrumental
piece of music I can think of that like
it's in my reign but it's not in the
form of language so like the most naive
reading of that hypothesis can't be
quite right yeah so Vic and Stein makes
this wonderful example where just to
show that some things are very
expressive well in language and others
not so he says if I ask you what's the
height of Mount Kilimanjaro if you know
the answer you can easily express it in
language but if I ask you what is it
clarinet
like it's gonna be really hard right if
I don't already know what a clarinet
sounds like I'm not going to be able to
say very many useful things that will
really help you
and so they're definitely a lot of
there's a lot of mental activity that
exists outside of the purview of
language or is not as effable and my
impression is that the sapir-whorf
hypothesis was popular and then faded
and maybe is getting a little bit to
come back it was popular when war force
writing people were damn it he was
writing in the 30s and 40s but a lot of
his writings were then published after
after his death there was a collection
of them published in the 50s but there
wasn't really any research about it
right so it's one thing for the idea to
be popular right it's another thing to
actually go and do experiments and one
of the reasons is that all of the people
doing work in communities that were not
just you know colleges in the US with
English speakers in you know English
speaking sophomores who are subjects yes
all of those people weren't using the
tools of cognitive psychology or
psychology in general they were
linguists or anthropologists they were
doing descriptive work and so when they
would come back from their field sites
and say well I worked in this community
and they do this psychologists would
treat that as like interesting stories
and travel journals they would be lovely
that you had that trip in color you had
that experience but it's not science and
but at the same time psychologists were
completely shielded from being able to
discover any of these fascinating
differences because they never left
their labs and the only people they ever
tested were English speaking sophomores
and so if that's our the only people you
have a test you never see evidence of
diversity so you've conveniently
protected yourself from discovering any
interesting phenomena right it's I mean
is is there a time when that began to
shift in the mid 1990s finally there's
there's there started to be a marriage
where inspiration from field linguistics
and linguistic anthropology started
filtering into psychology and then
psychologists started collaborating with
linguists and anthropologists to design
experiments and it it's a relationship
of building trust across those
disciplines because different fields
have different ways of knowing and
different things they trust to be true
and definitely as a you know I'm trained
as an experimentalist so I believe data
I want things to come from a controlled
experiment and if there's not two
columns of numbers I can compare I know
it's not it nothing is true right but at
the same time I've also come to see how
much of our interpretation of the data
has to rely on a rich understanding of
the context in which you collected the
data so if I go to a community for a
week and do an experiment 5% of what I
learn is the data that I got in the
experiment and 95% of what I learned is
just being there and seeing how people
interact and how whatever practice I'm
trying to measure in this little toy
experiment actually lives in the
community and how how it performs and
that gives me so much more comfort in
interpreting the data and making sure
that I'm not just grossly
misinterpreting what the two columns of
numbers are saying does that pose a
challenge for the practice of science
and that it's harder to objectively
communicate what you've learned in a
journal article than it is for some
quantitative data well I'm you know I'm
still an experimentalist so I'm always I
always am at the end of the day doing a
controlled experiment and doing
statistics on the data so that's true
but I think it is a really interesting
challenge for all of the behavioral
sciences and all of the social sciences
to think who are subjects of study are
right so when we're talking about humans
people a physicist I can avoid this
problem you can yeah yeah when we're
talking about humans usually people will
just test American undergrads and say we
we've discovered how humans do something
they're a very strange kind of human
that's a very very unusual kind of human
and
and how do you actually create a rich
understanding of the human mind in all
of the different contexts that it exists
and the incredible ingenuity and
flexibility that you see around the
world in all of these different contexts
that to me is the real cool stuff that
human minds do and the more we constrain
the set of people that we study the less
we're actually allowing ourselves to
understand they're the real meat of what
it is to be human what it is to have
this cool human brain that can do all
these things and is so flexible and even
if language does not absolutely restrict
what we can understand it does so it
does seem that the pendulum is swinging
towards thinking that it affects how we
understand things and maybe in a
profound way maybe not just you know
colors and directions it definitely
creates habits of thought it lays down
patterns that are easy to follow and
then you follow those patterns and in
some cases it creates foundations for
whole realms of thought so the domain of
number is a good example of that of
course in English we have numbers 1 2 3
4 5 everyone learns those numbers I
guess 0 came late 0 is very late yeah
well the decimal positional system that
we use now for representing numbers I
think comes to Europe and a 1700 s with
Fibonacci right so he takes it from the
Arab world which took it from India the
idea of counting numbers were always
there and always is a long time yeah we
don't know about always because you know
language doesn't leave a physical trace
in the fossil record so when you go
beyond the written record which is very
very short for the human race we
actually can only make inferences about
what might have been there so it's
extremely unlikely that always very good
but there are lots of languages that
don't have exact number words or have
words that are just 1 2 3 few and many
some languages don't use a base-10
system for their number system they use
base 6 or base 8 based
for base 87 you know 81 is true I
definitely know of it I think 120 was
something the Babylonians had a lot of
things that were based on 60s and 20s so
120 you get from units of 20s oh that
that was a common thing in general body
parts are good so 5 10 20 are common but
then some people use a different way of
thinking about body parts so for example
they might use links on your fingers and
so you get 12 some might use knuckles in
which case you get 8 and some people for
example there's a group in Papua New
Guinea that has a base 27 that just
starts with the fingers on one hand and
goes across the top of your body
including including parts of your face
in your head and goes on the other side
and so and then when you need to go
above 27 you just go in the other
direction and so you say you know a
second elbow second time back okay and
the body part terms are actually the
names of the numbers so like if you want
eight potatoes that's elbow potatoes so
languages have all these different
systems for numbers and some don't have
exact numbers at all and that's a case
where as you said zero came late in
human civilization so there are millions
of humans running around trying to think
about things and it takes a very special
one or group of humans to come up with
this very useful innovation of zero that
makes it a really good number system
that you can then you know like better
than the Roman numerals that Europeans
had before certainly for mental
calculation right but we all have we all
now completely take it for granted so
you and I know the number system it's
impossible to imagine not knowing it
it's impossible to imagine it ever not
being in in your language but someone
had to invent it and it's not something
that's a project for a Tuesday it took a
really long time for that to come about
and it didn't happen in in very many
places in the world and so but now we
have it and so we're like we're such
ungrateful punks we take it for granted
or like of course it always existed I
I would have thought of it if you know
if someone didn't but it's all this
cognitive labor of all these people that
has just built into language and now
five-year-olds have the cognitive skills
that used to be only available to a very
few adepts even just 500 years ago
because of that legacy of the built-in
structure though because it's just now
it's part of the language and everyone
is trained on it from early on and you
don't even remember learning it and I
completely unreadable for it but even
notions like causality influence and you
mentioned the billiard balls blame and
intentionality these are all built into
how we talk also yeah whenever something
happens you have to construe it in some
way right so there is a physical event
that occurs but then you also have to
think about did it just happen did
someone do it accident yeah and there's
so many different ways that language
allows you to construe describe any
given event so for example let me give
you a famous accident when Dick Cheney
went out hunting with his buddy Harry
Whittington and shot him accidentally in
the face yeah
so you could say Cheney shot Whittington
you could say Whittington got shot by
Cheney you could just say Weddington got
shot leave Cheney out of it altogether
you could focus on the matter so you
could say Weddington got peppered pretty
good that was a headline from a Texas
newspaper Cheney himself when he was
apologizing said ultimately I'm the guy
that pulled the trigger that fired the
round that hit Harry so I'm the guy that
pulled the trigger so he takes this you
know it doesn't take a very long time to
shoot your friend in the face it's a
split-second physical event you'd think
it's pretty simple but he takes a
split-second event and breaks it up into
a long chain and he just happens to be
on one end of that causal chain Bush
actually did one better he said
something like he heard a bird flush and
he turned and pulled the trigger and saw
his friend get wounded in that
description Cheney transforms from a
to mere witness by the end of the
sentence this is my masterful excavation
right now those things I give you those
examples they're funny like examples of
linguistic wiggling but we have to do
this all the time whenever you're
choosing a verb you're choosing how much
time you're going to compress into an
event so I could say we built Rome we
cured polio well a whole lot of things
had to happen it's a lot of events
there's a lot of time right for any of
those things so I can use one verb for
those extremely complex long-standing
processes or I could use four verbs to
say I shot my friend in the face so
you're always make taking a perspective
when you're choosing a verb and you're
also taking a perspective depending on
whether you say I broke the vase or the
vase broke or it so happened to me that
the vase broke you're shifting blame
you're shifting responsibility languages
choose differently how to describe
events so in English for example we are
not that careful about distinguishing
accidents from intentional actions so
you can say things like I broke my arm
where you know in lots of other
languages you wouldn't say that unless
you're a lunatic looking to go break
your arm and you succeeded right you
would say something to do my arm got
broken and it so happened to me that my
arm broke but in English whether it's
intentional or accidental it's common to
say an agentive thing like he broke the
vase I broke my arm
I lost the library book if you try to
say I lost the library book in Spanish
people look at you and say why would you
expand it should be different
constructions for I lost the library
book intentionally I lost it by accident
well yeah I mean if you're a weird
person who intentionally but you would
you would express it as something like
the look the book I lost or the book
lost itself to me or something like that
right because you didn't intend to do it
but in the case where say you're you
broke of Oz by accident and in English
you would sales to still say I broke it
that's normal and if you don't say I
broke it if you say something like it
broke people think it's evasive right
now whereas and lots of languages you
would have to use a different constrain
writers are taught not to use the
passive voice because it is
less-active is Weger right yeah this is
a like a gentle non-urgent if is a
little different perspective but let me
give you an example I love so take
Caesar Romeo
Socrates so Socrates drank the poison
Socrates was forced to drink poison he
knew that he was drinking poison he had
to do it as sentenced to death by poison
right Romeo drank the poison he meant to
drink poison he was intentionally
drinking poison right seize a drink
drink the poison what Caesar thought he
was drinking wine but his wine was
poisoned so he's intentionally drinking
but unknowingly to him it's poison right
so but in English we can say he drank
the poison in each case Caesar drank the
poison Romeo drank the poison Socrates
drank the poison there are languages
where those three would require
different grammatical constructions
because in those languages it's
important whether someone is doing
something knowingly whether they're
doing something willfully what whether
they're you know it's volitional and so
in debate for example this is a language
spoken in the Maldives you would use
three different constructions for those
three different guys because there are
circumstances that are importantly
different and have to be marked
dramatically differently in those
languages and and just like the ability
to you know keep track of numbers and so
forth I presume this does have an effect
on how we conceptualize the world a
little bit I mean mate this is probably
full employment for you and people in
your lab to figure out do we assign
praise and blame differently if we speak
one of these slightly different
languages are we more willing to let
things slide or are we more Dougy yeah
well so let me give you an example just
from English we did this experiment
right after the Super Bowl where Janet
Jackson and Justin Timberlake performed
together and they had this very famous
incident that became the world's first
wardrobe malfunction so the term
wardrobe malfunction was born after that
incident and the reason we chose that
incident is we wanted something that was
saturated for people that they had seen
it many times before
and they knew a lot about it that seemed
to discuss them in the news it you know
in case people don't remember in the
final dance move Justin Timberlake
reached across Janet Jackson's chest and
then for 9/16 of a second one of her
breasts was partially exposed on
national television and this was
extremely scandalous according to the
works yes the the FCC tried to find CBS
$550,000 for the indecency and people
were so outraged it quickly became the
most TiVoed event of all time go back
and review it just to make sure they
were extremely outraged yet again so we
thought well what if you take an event
that's even this saturated and you can
see it yourself with your own eyes you
can quote-unquote go to the tape right
so we have the sense in you know we have
a depression image let's go to the tape
as if if you just see it with your own
eyes you'll have direct perception of
reality right so I say okay well let's
go to the tape for something that you've
already seen many times anyway could we
still change the way people blame and
punish the people involved depending on
what grammatical construction we use to
describe it okay and so we showed people
the video we tell them either he
unfastened the snap or the snap
unfastened and then we ask how much is
he to blame and how much of the five
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
should he pay and not only do people
blame Timberlake more if we say he
unfastened the snap but they also want
to charge in fifty five percent more in
fines all right so the rubber hits the
road where yeah so even though you have
this feeling like I can see what
happened I can see it with my own eyes
the way that we describe things the way
we tend to describe this things or the
way things are framed for us by other
people makes a real difference even when
you can see things with your own eyes
yeah and presumably this pervades
everything in ways that we don't even
know I mean an obvious thing to discuss
is gender in language right there are
ongoing questions about pronouns in
English but other languages are way more
gendered than English is and some are
way less gender and some are way that's
right and so I mean one question is
when I took German in high school I was
told sure there's you know dere D and
Austin's these genders but there's
nothing whatsoever to do with you know
the sex of human beings or anything like
that I was always a little bit
suspicious that there was zero
connotation in the marine do we know
anything about how the existence of
those different labels affects how
people perceive the different things
yeah so this is a coming back to the
question you asked earlier about to what
extent does language reflect reality or
to what extent is it creating its own
reality I think this is a really
wonderful example of how language
creates something that is completely
unrelated to reality alright yeah so we
have these grammatical gender systems
where every noun is masculine or
feminine so chairs tables watering cans
toasters all have all are either
masculine or feminine and the amazing
thing is speakers of those languages
actually take those as meaningful right
and so if you ask even young kids for
example can you assign voices for
animated characters so we're gonna have
a toaster be the star of this animated
film what voice should it have young
kids who are learning Spanish or French
as their first language will take a boy
voice or a girl voice depending on the
grammatical gender of the noun adults
will give you different descriptions of
an object like a bridge depending on
whether it's masculine or feminine in
their language and if you ask
monolinguals of one of these languages
why is this word masculine in your
language or why is it feminine they'll
say well it reflects some reality about
the world it's completely different in a
differently exactly my language has
intuited something that is otherwise
invisible about this object you know the
son is masculine because it is truly
masculine and my language is simply
picking up like isn't it amazing that
French is such a sensitive language it's
picked up on the genders of all these
inanimate things
where's once you find bilinguals who
speak two languages that have different
gender systems then they start to see oh
well this is just a formal property of
the language and they won't they won't
say that so I think we believe the
structures of our languages a lot more
than we should we often believe that the
categories that happen to exist in our
language are the structure of reality
but in fact lots of other categories are
possible
those categories could be collapsed or
they could be refined and all of those
are simply models so when we go back to
gender for humans for example if you
have a language that requires humans to
be either male or female in the language
so you have to have he or she and
there's no other way it's easy to come
to believe that that's a necessary
distinction and you could not think of a
human unless you put them in one of
those two categories but if you speak a
language that doesn't actually make that
distinction lots of languages don't have
any gender marking in that case it's not
a problem it actually doesn't even occur
to you as a thing to worry about right
and I mean it's only one of a million
different ways we could distinguish
between people right yeah assign to
pronoun - well I mean it's it it is
interesting the gender is one of the
only things that languages mark on
pronouns some languages will worry about
age so there there are a couple of other
things that get encoded but gender is
one of the only things that you note and
you could argue that from an information
point of view other things might be more
useful like you could encode height or
eye color or education level or you know
ability to curl twenty pounds or
whatever it is that you could want you
you could want to know about someone but
we focus on this but also people often
feel very very attached to whichever
specific way like their language does
gender so for example in English people
might be very adamant that you can't
replace P and G with a because you have
to have gendered pronouns and how could
you speak a language that doesn't have
gender like what would pronouns even
mean I always point out that in fact
almost all pronouns in English are
already gender-neutral so I we they you
in fact only third-person singular
pronouns have gender and I've never
heard someone say you know what we
really need to add more gender to the
other pronouns something we just do that
Tai has different gendered words for I
Hebrew has different gendered words for
you Spanish has different gender words
for they plural right so you could
advocate for that but I've just never
heard someone say that
people feel very attached to whichever
way their language happens to be in the
moment but these things do can and do
change do you think it is changing do
you think we're gonna switch to a a
third-person universal pronoun you think
we should so singularly today has
existed in English for a really long
time there are lots of classical uses
that that people don't even hear is
strange at all so if I say if anybody
calls tell them I'm not home
that's an indeterminate person my bones
you can find these examples and
Shakespeare and Jane Austen and you know
it's it's an old use if you know the
gender of the person then you use he or
she but if you don't use thing yeah and
so the use of singular day is on their
eyes in English people like it they use
it and so as it becomes more popular
people continue to like it and use it
it's going to sound more and more normal
and the few cases where there's some
ambiguity or or difficulty in parsing
because you don't know if it's singular
plural you'll just resolve those with
context over time or people will come up
with other solutions whether it's
something whether I would prescribe
something is like they should or
shouldn't I think it really depends on
what purpose you're trying would goal
you're trying to achieve right so a lot
of languages are trying to come up with
gender-neutral ways of speaking because
categorizing people into just two
categories misses a lot of people who
don't feel like they could cleanly be
categorized into the those two
categories or sometimes because they
feel like it puts too much emphasis on
gender and the first thing that you
experience about it someone is gender it
allows implicit bias to creep in and so
on but other languages are adding more
gender right so for example in French
the Academie Francaise that's is the the
body that decides what isn't isn't heart
officially part of it can you French
yeah they've just approved a whole bunch
of new feminine forms for professions
and so the idea is that it creates
visibility for the fact that there are
female surgeons and there are female
soldiers and there are female bosses and
there are female presidents right and so
you could say that's a good thing
because if there are women doing those
jobs
you hear the feminine form it creates a
norm that women do exist in these
positions of power but at the same time
it it has a potential to backfire
because for a lot of cases it doesn't
matter the gender of the person doesn't
matter for their job right so if I say
the statistician delivered the results
or something like that well if I'm
required to mark that it's a female
statistician as opposed to a male
statistician does that allow you to
start thinking about your gender biases
about who can do math and who can't do
math is a female statistician a
different job than a middle statistician
in the same way that Actress is seen as
a less prestigious job than actor or
waitress is seen as a less prestigious
job than waiter the female actors I know
in Hollywood like to be called actors
exactly because there's more prestige
associated with the male term and
there's more Pacey I don't know French
very well is that is the existing French
nouns implicitly male marked and they're
trying to add a female version of it so
like I can imagine women not wanting to
say well I'm doing a man doing that job
either so it's a sticky situation I
don't know what where to go the forms
for a lot of jobs the forms that exist
are explicitly masculine forms and so
the economy font-size is just to approve
the feminine verb almost any profession
can be easily feminized in French the
way that French's is constructed it's
just that they weren't approved as
official things that you could put in a
newspaper he and in any yes
yeah or add an e at the end depending on
the right area yeah okay well I don't
know I mean how so this is a good place
to wrap up I mean you're a scientist you
describe what happens in the world how
people talk how it affects their lives
and things like that but you're also a
person you know you have some
preferences how how much do you either
feel or need to resist the urge to be
judgey to say well it would be better if
we spoke this way like you know you
appreciate a lot more than the average
person how the way that we use language
affects how we think about things
does it make you want to go oh just stop
this way oh well I think of language as
a tool right and so I think that the way
you talk should serve the purposes that
you're trying to achieve and so for me
for example with respect to gender I
think it would be really great to have
gender as something that's optional so
when you want to include it when it's
relevant you include it and when you
don't want to include or it's not
relevant you don't include it in the
same way that you do for almost any
other personal characteristic so I can
talk about you without ever mentioning
your height or your eye color or your
religion or your profession and if I
want to include that information it's
optional I can do it it's it's not hard
it's not forbidden right but it's just
not part of every single utterance yeah
and so I think that system is that would
be really nice so if if I had if I had
to make a new language I would make a
language that makes it possible to not
include information when it's harmful or
problematic to include it and then to
include it when it's useful and in this
language would time move from left to
right or right actually you know English
time doesn't move left to right or right
to left in the languages do some
languages do it there is so every time I
say on the radio that English doesn't
layout time from left to right in in
metaphors so we don't say Tuesday is
left of Wednesday for example I get a
phone call from someone in the military
that says actually we say that and it's
because in the military they have this
calendar this perpetual calendar that
runs from left to right and everything
is scheduled in that left-to-right
stream and in fact it's starting to
become a linguistic metaphor so people
when they're shifting schedules will say
I'm shifting left or and so it is and
some some of my collaborators here at
UCSD have started testing speakers of
military English and in fact they they
do say things that speakers of
non-military English civilian English
would find to be odd or ungrammatical
but they have a structured particular
way of using left and right and their
metaphors that have come from this
artifact of this perpetual left-right
stream calendar well you already know
that for every rule we try to invent
there's gonna be exception since
we keep mining humans keep innovating
that's the wonderful thing about the
human mind is we have infinite
possibility in there I agree with that
one all right Larry Bard is he thanks so
much for the only mine Ski podcast all
right thank you for having me it's been
fun
[Music]
you
[Music]